- Open oven,
take out my crust.
Pour caramel over my crust.
- Yeah!!
Hey guys, it's me, Katie
and this is another episode
of Lost in Translation.
Why am I dressed up as an egg?
Because it is a very
special Halloween episode.
(ghostly moan)
As always, we take a recipe,
we put into Google Translate.
It goes from English
to Korean to Sudanese,
and many, many many more
until finally back to English
to give us this hilariously
translated recipe.
Does anyone think Jasmine
is getting too good at this?
Yes. Me too.
So today I have her facing off
against a professional pastry chef.
Will her experience
as a professional pastry
chef give her the leg up
or will Jasmine's translation
expertise get her the win?
Let's find out.
(ghostly moan)
There you go.
- Okay.
- Thank you. (apprehensive cry)
Also, you guys might notice
that Kelly's not here today.
We got a surprise call from her yesterday
and she's having her baby! (excited yell)
All the love to you.
If you wanna spread the love to her,
put it in the comments below.
We wish her and the Paige
family all the best.
- We miss you Kelly!
- Thank You.
- Okay! Let's do it.
- [Both] A scary bike.
- How do you eat a bike?
I don't know.
This is just too much to process for food.
- Step number one.
- Step one.
- [Both] "350 Fire in the oven."
I know that one.
Preheat the oven to 350.
- So I think 350 fire in the oven
can only mean preheat the oven to 350.
- I'll be right back.
- I'm gonna go do that.
- "Flour tip.
Put two cups of sandwich flour
in a meat grinder until smooth.
Add four tablespoon of oil and stir."
- Put two cups of, I would
assume, all purpose flour?
Bread flour?
I'm just gonna go with regular flour.
- I'm really scared going up
against a pastry chef today.
I might hop on this
scary bike and ride away.
Bread flour, all-purpose
flour, and cake flour.
Cake flour.
- Four tablespoons of oil.
I feel like that's actually
butter, unsalted butter maybe?
So I think meat grinder means blender.
- "In a meat grinder until smooth."
I'm gonna add two cups of sandwich flour
to my meat grinder here
and I'm getting it really nice and smooth.
Confidence level currently is at a three.
We'll build it.
- I think right now
we're making a pie dough.
Add four tablespoons of oil,
which I think is butter. Stir.
- Four tablespoons of oil and stir.
Butter.
But I feel like it's oil.
I do feel like it's oil.
I'll do canola.
Four tablespoons though?
This doesn't feel right.
Well, I've certainly stirred
and now it is resisting.
Given how I feel a hint at
this moment is quite necessary
and I want it from Mimo.
And Mimo is going to...
Draw it!
Wow, this is quite good.
A lamp shelf.
Oh, it's a person.
It's you!
It's butter!
(congratulatory applause)
This is the second masterpiece
from Lost in Translation, season two.
Comment below why you
deserve this art piece
and we will send it to
you personally signed.
Because Katie says I can't undo this step,
I'm just gonna have to move
forward with my oily flour.
When I make pies, I use cold butter
and I pulse it in a food processor.
Stir.
- I think that's good.
Let's see what's next.
- Step number three.
- "Pour batter into eight cake pan."
- I have no batter!
- "Click below and go
towards the activity tray."
- Ha. Transfer the pie crust
into a baking dish and
push against the sides.
- Eight cake pan?
This is not cake. Pie pan?
That looks like it might be eight inches.
It's not a pie pan, but it's a tart pan.
Click below and go
towards the activity tray.
I do not know what that could mean.
You know what, we're just gonna,
we're just gonna flour this a little bit.
Poor batter.
This is not ready.
- Ooh, Tart!
I have a feeling that it's
going to be the tart pan
and I'm going towards the activity tray
which means adding it
to my baking dish here
and I'm pushing it against
the edges of the dish.
- I think I need to stop and take a hint.
Hint box.
Let's do Mimo.
Sing it.
- ♪ You've made your batter. ♪
♪ It's made of flour. ♪
♪ So go ahead and and use your batter. ♪
♪ The end. ♪
- (excited yell)
- Oh! Okay.
I think that means pour it
out and knead the dough.
- This looks good.
Even though it's the most
oily pie crust I've ever made.
I am putting holes in the crust.
So it has some room to breathe.
- Click. Click you use your fingers right?
Click, click. Push it into the pan.
Knead this into a dough.
This feels like it's not coming together
like it would be a pie dough.
- Step number four. "Add the mixture
to the flavor and leave it for 12 minutes.
- Remove a wire rack to cool."
- Okay, so I think this is my mixture.
The flavor is the oven and
we're gonna cook for 12 minutes
and then afterwards we'll remove
it to a wire rack to cool.
- I must have missed something somewhere.
I need to put water in here?
We're just gonna do that
until it becomes a dough.
Before I had every expectation of failing
but now I'm failing harder than I thought.
This is embarrassing.
I swear I bake better than this.
- I will be right back.
(ghostly moan)
- So we're gonna roll this out.
We're gonna put it in there.
"Click below and go
towards the activity tray."
So I think that means push it in the pan.
I'm just gonna take off the top
Since I decided that this is a tart,
we're just gonna dock it.
We're gonna bake it for 12 minutes now.
- Step number five.
"Mix a quarter cup water and
one cup sugar in a small bowl.
- Leave on the fire so does not dissolve."
- They are placed in the
electrified syrup for 10 minutes."
- I feel like this makes more sense to me.
We're mixing one cup sugar and a cu--
a quarter cup of water.
"Leave on fire," which
could mean the stove.
Are we making caramel?
- Sauce pan!
I'm gonna add a quarter cup water.
Sugar, I think is just granulated sugar.
So a cup of that.
"Leave on the fire so does not dissolve."
I think,
although contradicting itself,
I do think it's stir until dissolve.
You're not supposed to
stir water and sugar,
but I'm just getting the lump of it gone.
- I don't wanna touch it
cause then it'll crystallize.
So you kind of have to let
sugar and water do its thing.
- Step number six.
"As soon as the sugar is
completely dissolved immediately
add half cup of flour and mix.
Carefully pour in half cup
of the cream all at once."
- I don't like this anymore.
- Oh my my.
Okie dokie.
Cream I think is heavy cream.
Flour I think might be flour.
- Why would you add flour?
I really think being a pastry chef
is hindering my ability to process this.
- Smelling this step has made me realize
we are probably making caramel.
So for "immediately
add half cup of flour",
I think it's to add
half a cup of caramels.
First my half cup cream.
I've chosen heavy whipping cream.
I've added my cream.
Now I'm gonna remove it from the heat.
I'm gonna use the residual
heat to melt down my caramels.
So now I am going to mix.
- I need a hint.
So I'm picking Katie.
- [Katie] Oh my god.
Earlier it was known as oil
and sometimes it's wrapped in foil.
- Butter. So I got my butter.
Sugar and water is electrified.
Butter's melted.
And then we're gonna put cream.
- Next step while I stir.
- Step seven.
- "Remove the pan from the oven--
- And stir in red salt is blood."
Oh!
- Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
- So remove the pan from the oven,
which is the pie pan,
which has been baking.
- I'm removing pan from heat
and I'm gonna stir in red food coloring.
- Sure, take a look.
- Red salt is blood, which I
know has to be caramel now.
This is a red blood and I'm
gonna put this in the tart pan.
- Oh my gosh.
Is it Hot Tamales?
I think red salt is red food coloring.
And this will be our blood.
I'm just gonna add until I
think it's blood colored.
- So I think stir is pour.
Caramel is blood.
- While I stir, I'm gonna
move on to the next step.
- Step eight.
- "Sprinkle blood candy
on biscuits are the end
and put in the freezer if you want."
- If you want!
- Do I want?
- I'm just gonna see what we have.
It could be anything.
- Oh, is my biscuit my tart crust?
- Scary. Black licorice is pretty scary.
- I love black licorice.
- What is red that you can sprinkle?
- Wait, I think it might be shortbread
on a shortbread crust?
Um. Uh. I find myself a little puzzled.
So I think it calls for the hint box.
♪ The hint box. ♪
All right, Katie, I would like you to...
Act it!
Open oven.
Take out my crust.
Poor caramel over my crust.
- Yeah!
- Hot tamales.
You know what? I'm, I
think it's Hot Tamales.
I don't know why.
It's red.
It's candy.
None of this makes sense.
It's gonna look like a bicycle wheel.
I don't think bike is bike,
but I'm making it bike.
- So now I'm sprinkling
my blood candy all in.
Oh yeah, this looks good.
Since I want to, I am gonna
put this in the freezer.
- Do I want to? I think I do
to cool it down and let it set.
So we're gonna put it in the freezer.
An undetermined amount of time.
We're just gonna say like 30 minutes.
- Step number nine. "Tato ice chocolate:
- Six ounces chocolate and
half bat butter in a bowl."
- Half bat?
Half cup?
Half stick of butter.
- This is a bat?
- [Katie] Why is that a bat?
- Bat. Baseball. Stick.
Baseball bat stick.
Half stick butter.
- And then we need six
ounces of chocolate.
This is a nice medium.
Semi-sweet chocolate.
- Chocolate. But what kind of chocolate?
Ooh! Dark semi-sweet.
I think that would be
semi-sweet chocolate chips.
And I'm gonna do half a bat of butter.
- Six ounces.
Can I cut this in half?
Cut it down.
- Step number 10.
- "Heat a small sauce pan over medium heat
or pour in two-thirds cup
cream until it fevers."
- What do you mean, or?
- Fevers probably means
it gets really hot.
So I'm gonna get a small sauce pan.
We're making ganache.
This is, could only be ganache.
- All right.
So I think two-third cup cream
is two-third cup heavy whipping cream.
Into the sauce pan it goes.
I'm just gonna put this on the heat
until it comes to a simmer.
So I'm just heating the
two-thirds cup of cream
until it fevers.
- So I'm just gonna wait
till this gets steamy.
- Step number 11. "Pour the hot oil
into a bowl with the chocolate.
Let stand for five minutes--
- then stir until smooth,
shiny, and smooth." Again.
- I love that.
Okay, so I think this is my hot oil
and I'm gonna pour this
over my butter and
chocolate and let it sit.
- Pour the hot oil which is the hot cream.
It just means to let it melt.
We're gonna cover it.
Five minutes.
Then we're gonna stir.
- I'm just gonna cover this up
so it melts a little faster.
- I'm a huge chocolate fan.
The fact that this is chocolate
and caramel, I am stoked.
- I think I'm making some sort of ganache?
- So it has to be like double smooth.
- All right, let's move
on to the next step.
- Step 12. "Top the ganache is the name
with caramel shells and spread evenly.
Ice for 10 minutes."
- This guy here, ganache is his name.
I'm gonna go get my blood pie.
I'm gonna pour this on top of it,
which is the caramel shells.
Spread it evenly,
and then back to the
freezer for 10 minutes.
- We top the ganache
over the caramel shell,
which is the tart.
Spread it evenly.
Ice has to mean chill.
We're gonna put that in the refrigerator
and chill it, "ice" for 10 minutes.
- Step number 13. "Make the webpage:
- Place two cups this is foam
in a large bowl for the microwave--
- And cook for 20 to 40
seconds to soften the balls.
Stirring occasionally."
- This is gonna be fun.
- ♪ We're making marshmallows. ♪
♪ We're making marshmallows. ♪
- Oh!
This has to be marshmallows
because they're foamy.
- Well, is there anything
there that's like, foamy?
- I don't wanna like,
wanna look cause I have to like my gut.
- Mini marshmallows, big marshmallows.
Cool Whip, Jet Puff.
I mean these are foamy.
I've never microwaved marshmallow
but I've always wanted to.
So I think for that reason
alone, we've gotta do that.
- I think Heather definitely
chose marshmallows.
And I have a feeling Heather
is really nailing this.
- We're not gonna measure it.
- Now I'm gonna soften these balls
in the microwave in 20
to 40 second intervals.
- So now we're going to microwave
this for 20, 30 seconds.
- Step number 14. "Let the
margarine stand for a few minutes
and then lift it, press it,
and rub it with your fingers
creating a fluffy effect,
they put it on the author.
- Margarine.
- So I think this is my margarine.
I'm gonna let it stand for a
few minutes to cool slightly.
- I need a hint and I'm
gonna get it from Mimo.
Act it!
(Katie celebrating)
It is a bowl?
And then you're mixing and
you're pulling. Spreading?
Oh, we're stretching it!
We're stretching what we had!
We're stretching the marshmallow!
- Create a fluffy effect.
Lift it, press it, rub it.
Wow, that looks so good.
- This is perfect.
Get my hands cold.
Oh, this is very weird but satisfying.
- I've never done
anything like this before
but this is quite fun.
If this is wrong, I don't wanna be right.
- It's a spider web!
- This is a lot messier, actually,
than I thought it was gonna be.
But this works and, um, I'm
now gonna go wash my hands.
(laughing)
Step number 15.
- "Prepare the arachnid.
- Sprinkle the black licorice slices
with the sliced licorice and
stir in the sliced licorice,
stir in the onions and
stir in the onions."
- There is a lot of
licorice and onions in this.
- So I'm gonna be making a spider.
- It's clearly a spider.
- Sprinkle he black licorice slices.
I do feel like I saw some licorice.
- Black licorice.
Woo! Yeah!
- Onions. Garlic. Garlic bulb. bulb ball.
Whoppers! Whoppers!
Maybe Whoppers with like
little legs coming out?
- So sprinkling has to be just placing.
Stir in the onions.
No, no onions in this.
Stir.
We can say cut.
We're gonna cut little legs.
- I think this is licorice number one
and licorice number two.
And I think sliced licorice is these legs.
I must cut them into little legs.
We got an arachnid.
- There's my two spiders.
- I've never had black licorice before.
- What?
Wait, you've never had black licorice?
What?!
- Why does it taste like medicine?
- Step number 16.
"Almond paste with
chocolate to cover the body.
- And send the chocolate to the head
so that the stars are
scattered in the center."
- Excuse me?
- I thought I made the body,
but it's not good enough I see.
- Almond paste to cover the body.
I actually think this means to like,
add just a little dot to the body.
There's also raisins.
Oh, maybe the raisin.
I'm not putting raisins in my dessert.
That's ridiculous.
Oh, there is sprinkles!
- Chocolate covered almonds
makes sense for the body.
'Cause I don't have to mold anything.
- I do think the second half
is to sprinkle on some sprinkles.
All right.
It's happening.
Ooh, it's cute.
- And then the stars are
scattered in the center.
Sprinkles. We're gonna
go back to these guys.
I'm putting chocolate chips on the body
because these are the stars
scattered in the center.
♪ I am on the last line. ♪
- [Both] "Explore and enjoy!"
- I'm gonna plate it.
- I think that means you're done.
We're gonna pull it outta the pan.
It looks like a cheesy pizza.
(deep breathing)
- Are you zombie?
- Explore and enjoy.
Oh! I'm done. So curious to
see what Heather's looks like.
- [Both] Hello, hello!!
- You did it.
- I did it and it was really stressful.
- I'm excited to see what you made.
Let's bring our dishes out
before we see the original dish.
Oh God. I really wanna know
what you chose for foamy balls.
- [Katie] And open your eyes.
- [Both] Oh!
- [Heather] Yours is bleeding.
- [Jasmine] Wow.
Well, I'm happy we did the
marshmallow thing similarly.
- [Heather] Yes. Yes.
- [Jasmine] I was very nervous about that
and it was quite messy.
- Did you use the bowl
of ice water underneath?
- No. Did you?
- You did phenomenal. And I
would definitely hire you.
- Wow, thank you.
Shall we bring out the original dish?
- [Heather] Oh yeah.
- [Jasmine] Wow!!! We did great!
- [Heather] Oh my god.
This is so...
- [Jasmine] This is so good!
What is this called?
- [Katie] So this is called
this Spooky Spider Tart.
- So where did you find this recipe?
- We were inspired by some things online
but Mimo actually told us about
the marshmallow web thing.
- [Jasmine] So let's try each other's
and then we'll try the original dish.
I like the blood look, nice and gory.
- [Heather] I think we should
try yours first for sure.
Mmm. It's ultra caramel.
- [Jasmine] Now can we try yours?
- [Heather] If we have to.
- Wait.
- Yes.
- Gummy Hot Tamale.
- Yes!!
- I was like, mmm, texture.
Was it?
- It's a fun surprise.
- [Jasmine] We've tried them both.
Shall we try the original recipe?
- [Heather] Oh yeah.
- Oh, there's red inside.
- [Jasmine] Wow!!
- Cheers!
- [Jasmine] Hm. So smooth.
- [Heather] Proper.
[Jasmine] That ganache.
- I did sad.
- What!? No.
I think overall we did really good.
- [Katie] Look how similar
these are all though.
- [Heather] They are similar though, yeah.
- All right guys, thanks
so much for watching.
Heather, thank you so much for joining us
on this special Halloween episode.
And everyone make sure
to tune in next week
because we have an exciting season finale.
See ya.
- [Both] Bye!!
(ghostly moans)
Can I have a meditation break?
- Meditation break?
You haven't even looked at it.
- I need Kelly singing.
She's too busy screaming right now.
- Welcome back.
We should name our hot plate.
Hot Plate Pete.